*A REALLY LOUD AND A ANNOYING INTRO*
<3
Oh hello
Who's shooting the arrows?
I'm a... I'm a friendly box who loves to..
ya know  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
oh my god
FUCK ALL OF YOU
PLS I'm being shanked
FUUCK ALL OF YAAO
oh oh GOD
I didn't even mean to kill that one
oh oh oh
This is so much better than Overwatch
I hear you guys
I SEE you guys (you creepy pervert) going
NO NON NO
*PewDiePie screaming really loudly into the mic yo make our ears bleed! - RIP Ears...*
my log...sheuhwsads
My Logistics are unmatched
FFFFFuck you poopipie ff
WHAT
YOU STOOPID FELIX BEHIND YOU
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
WOW WHAT A SNEAKY BITCH
Some call it camping, others call it...
BOXING
where'd you go
you heal after a while if you run out of battery
OHH NO NO NO
HA HA
OHHHH
you will never fin... OHHH
AAAAHAHAHAA
*sniper elite v5*
PEWDIE where are you
i SEE you jack (there he is again)
NO YOU DON'T GO AWAY
LEAVE ME ALONE
AHHHH
YEEAAAH
FUCK IT
(this is how is sound when i do push ups)
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
NOOOOOOO
come here come here come here
suck it
WHAT yoU DOING NEXT TO ME YOU FUCK
YOU TRYNA HIDE??? COME BACK HERE
you fuck
i hate all of you guys y'all suck y'all aren't even good boxers
*secksy burp*
that's right that's right i said it
YE PUSHED ME DOWN
Hey Poopiepie
No where are you?
no no
You're not shooting..
anywhere
you're not even shooting me
where are you?
FUCK YOU FUCK YOU FUCJ YOU MARK FUCK YOU
NO WRONG BOX ITS NOT ME
fuck you
told you i'd get you poopiepie
ah damn it he got poopiepie
JEEZUZ
NO NO YOU FUCKING SON OF... SON OF... you PUZZIES AS BIZ
BID..BITCH yeah dats right
you guys have been box, get it? sorry huh huh
jesus